hey this is B peppers from candy crush
soda saga tips and this is a candy crush
soda saga level 80 walkthrough in the
beginning I'm just gonna play
I don't have a lot of choices so it's
pretty straightforward but what I'm
trying to do here is work my way down so
that I can get to be us the special
candies that are trapped at the bottom
ideally I want to UM you know make
specials like this combos strike plus
the fish here should take it out a row
yeah and I'd like to make a combo with
the collar and candy that's the biggest
best way to ensure that you're gonna get
everything but as you can see like right
now I'm kind of stopped I can't really
work my way down to forced to make some
moves at the top and that's a good
shuffle because really like working on
the ones at the top aren't important
you'll catch those in cascades so what
you want to do like the guide and the
Kate so you know you just want to UM
work towards those specials at the
bottom here I'm a little bit less
enthusiastic about matching strike the
fish but I still have to because you see
there one somewhere that wasn't really
useful or else it could also go across
the middle and waste the coloring cane
so I guess that was lucky enough but you
know I'm still trying to work my way
down that's still the main priority
that was kind of a mistake I think what
I should have done I was looking at the
fish and I was trying to I was gonna
make another fish later but um I think
what I probably should have done was
just make a vertical that would have hit
the blocker in between um all right so
here that's actually pretty good because
I know that that stripes gonna go across
that way and now if I can make another
special here there's a good chance I'll
be able to match it because I can even
if I can't get the blocker that's right
next to the right next to the collar and
Katie I can I can possibly get the one
below it and then it'll fall down there
too so I'm just gonna try to make some
other specials and bring them down kind
of block on the left yeah that'll work
and then like I said here that puts a
fish right next to it so I don't know if
we're gonna be able to finish but this
will make a lot of headway so hopefully
the last two moves we'll be able to
clear up
all right so we have two pieces of ice
that have that are covering the vanity
that aren't so hopefully whenever I set
off this fish here it'll go after one of
the ones that is on me yeah oh and I
could have matched the green but it all
worked out so that's what you do it yet
like I said you just want to move in the
direction of the special candies and
they made it a little bit easier than it
used to be but the strategy is still the
same don't worry about the top just go
straight down and then if you can put a
special candy next to that color in
candy and you can see how quickly that
can get things going alright thanks for
watching our video like it if you found
it helpful
visit our site and I will be making more
new videos soon